Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Salvare un castello pensando,
credendo,
che potesse bastare
la sola forza delle idee.
Da questo costruire
un gruppo, la fondazione.
Con la fondazione viaggiare
su un doppio binario parallelo:
da una parte il restauro
conservativo e filologico,
dall'altra il suo riutilizzo
come un sistema culturale locale.
Ma dove siamo?
Siamo a Padernello,
una piccola frazione di 76 abitanti
nel comune di Borgo San Giacomo,
in provincia di Brescia.
Siamo nella "Bassa" più bassa
della bassa bresciana.
Una chiesa, cinque, sei
grandi cascine, un castello.
Il castello è un castello medioevale:
nasce come torre di avvistamento
verso la fine del 1300.
Nel 1400, la famiglia Martinengo -
siamo nel periodo delle lotte
fra Milano e Venezia,
il fiume Oglio fa da confine -
questa famiglia Martinengo
costruisce questi palazzi.
Verso il 1485 - 1490
viene un po' concluso come casa fortezza.
Verso la fine del Cinquecento
viene sopralzato,
e prende le attuali forme.
Verso la metà del Settecento
viene trasformata
in una residenza signorile.
[Nel] 1834 muore questo
Girolamo Silvio Martinengo.
Non ha discendenti,
e la passa alla famiglia Salvadego.
Perché vi racconto questo?
Perché la famiglia Salvadego, poi,
lo abiterà fino al 1965.
Dal 1965 fino al 2005
questo castello resterà disabitato,
all'incuria del tempo,
degli uomini, delle persone.
I piccioni avevano fatto
dei danni inenarrabili,
avevano fatto delle cose impensabili.
Ecco, nel 2002 c'è l'ultimo crollo.
Sembrava l'ultimo messaggio
che il castello stava mandando:
o ci salvate, o mi salvate,
o io crollo e questo bene storico
lo perdiamo completamente.
Ci aveva provato un'associazione,
per un po' di tempo,
a mettere in campo alcune iniziative:
ma sono sempre quelle cose
dove crediamo che la bellezza
sia sempre la cosa che ci muove di più.
La bellezza, se non diventa
un valore patrimoniale, non è sufficiente!
Ecco che, allora,
il comune di Borgo San Giacomo
decide di fare l'acquisto.
Quando sta per acquistarlo,
alla fine entrano le solite problematiche:
il Comune non ce la fa,
ci sono i patti di stabilità.
Ecco che allora inventiamo
la prima operazione:
l'acquisto lo facciamo pubblico-privato.
Il 51% è del Comune,
il bene è indiviso, è del Comune;
il 49% è di privati.
Il pubblico e privato messi insieme:
sembrava il diavolo e l'acquasanta.
Invece, questa cosa funziona.
Poi, nello stesso anno,
dopo aver fatto l'acquisto
il 31 maggio 2005,
il 15 dicembre del 2005
costituiamo la fondazione,
una fondazione di partecipazione.
E anche questa è una forma innovativa,
che suggerisco:
qualsiasi persona, ente,
debba aiutare la rinascita
di un bene culturale,
fate una fondazione di partecipazione.
È un ente pubblico di diritto privato
che dà la velocità,
che ti permette di fare le cose veloci.
Ma prima di fare le cose veloci, pensiamo.
Prima dell'azione, il pensiero.
Noi abbiamo speso
uno studio di fattibilità,
ci abbiamo pensato, ci abbiamo riflettuto
e poi l'abbiamo presentato
in Sovrintendenza.
Togliamo un altro mito:
"La sovrintendenza non ti aiuta mai".
Siamo andati dalla sovrintendenza;
abbiamo presentato il progetto;
dopo 15 giorni avevamo
il parere del Sovrintendente
che autorizzava a partire,
a fare questo restauro.
Vedete che, se le cose vengono fatte
con capacità, e anche con competenza,
le cose funzionano,
in un pensiero progettuale.
L'altra cosa l'abbiamo fatta, anche,
con la costituzione della fondazione.
Avremmo potuto mettere delle persone
che si erano fatte avanti,
ma abbiamo selezionato
chi poteva entrare a fare i soci fondatori.
Cinque banche di credito cooperativo,
quindi che sono deputate
a salvaguardare il territorio,
e quindi le abbiamo unite.
La Cogema, che è una società di servizi
del nostro territorio
che rappresenta 70 comuni;
il comune di Borgo
San Giacomo, naturalmente;
e poi la società di privati;
e poi altri privati.
11 soci fondatori,
a cui abbiamo fatto versare
una piccola quota di partenza.
Da lì siamo partiti
per cominciare a fare
le opere di restauro.
Perché, quando siamo arrivati,
noi avevamo di fronte un grande problema:
il castello è caduto, è crollato.
L'abbiamo trasformato
in una grande opportunità.
La visione che, quando abbiamo
un problema, noi ci fermiamo
è una cosa che deve essere superata:
il problema è una grande opportunità.
Ecco che questo noi l'abbiamo fatto.
Mentre cominciavamo -
abbiamo fatto la fondazione, vi dicevo,
nel 2005 a fine anno;
all'inizio del 2006,
già cominciavamo a restaurare i tetti.
Quindi, man mano facevamo le iniziative,
andavano avanti e quindi
facevamo anche le manifestazioni.
Quindi, da una parte ristrutturavano,
dall'altra parte riutilizzavamo.
Quindi siamo partiti subito, nel 2006,
con il restauro della parte crollata;
nel 2007 abbiamo restaurato
la parte che era dedicata
alle librerie e alle biblioteche,
abbiamo cominciato a fare teatro
e a presentare i libri;
nel 2008 e 2009 abbiamo risistemato
tutta la parte del cortile
con un grande bando
della fondazione Cariplo
verso la creazione di sistemi culturali;
e lì abbiamo fatto un po'
il salto di qualità,
ci siamo un po' sdoganati,
siamo andati un po' a livello regionale.
E abbiamo cominciato a fare le iniziative
perché, dicevamo, abbiamo restaurato
il cortile, le facciate, lo scalone;
ma abbiamo fatto partire subito
cinque iniziative.
Tra le quali questa, Slow Food.
Quando io ho cominciato,
i miei amici dicevano:
ma sì, facciamo il mercato,
venderemo due caciottelle.
Scherzavano.
Di mercati Slow Food, attualmente,
in Lombardia ce ne sono due:
uno a Milano, e uno a Padernello.
Uno ha qualche milione di persone;
noi abbiamo 76 abitanti.
Il mercato ci porta 3.000 persone
ogni domenica che facciamo il mercato.
Facciamo la terza domenica del mese,
quindi vuol dire che questo
ci porta 30.000 persone.
Sapete quante iniziative
facciamo in un anno?
200 - 220 giorni
di manifestazioni in un anno.
Facciamo 220 giorni
di manifestazioni all'anno,
e facciamo, da zero, 60.000 visitatori.
Quindi vuol dire che abbiamo
attivato questo processo.
Ma perché abbiamo fatto questa cosa qui?
Perché non abbiamo ascoltato
quelli che dicono:
questi beni devono essere salvati
dallo Stato, dalla Regione, dal Comune.
Questi beni li salviamo noi,
perché questi beni noi li amiamo.
Perché noi crediamo fortemente che,
se abbiamo la forza,
la capacità, la competenza -
la passione, questa parola discriminante
che diventa questa grande virtù:
la perseveranza!
Che se noi abbiamo la passione
che dura nel medio-lungo periodo,
siamo in grado di fare
piani strategici quinquennali,
capire quali sono le soluzioni,
creare quello che dicevamo,
un progetto che qui vedete identificato.
I nove progetti.
Siamo stati in grado
di mettere in campo nove progetti:
il teatro; il cinema; enogastronomia;
le mostre; il progetto culturale.
E attraverso tutti questi progetti -
in cui ognuno ha un responsabile,
e ognuno è uno sponsor:
nove progetti, nove sponsor,
nove responsabili.
Ecco dove viaggiamo: la visione è chiara,
la mission è chiarissima, trasparente,
per cui quando andiamo
a fare una ricerca fondi -
che credetemi,
è una ricerca fondi pazzesca
perché noi non lasciamo perdere niente:
facciamo il piano A,
se non va il piano A abbiamo il B,
poi abbiamo il C, di scorta.
Perché, naturalmente, capite bene
che in un luogo come questo -
perché questa è una terra dura,
di fatica, di sudore,
non è che ti regalano niente.
E poi, a Padernello ci devi arrivare
per forza in stradine piccole strette,
sono i vecchi limes romani
che abbiamo mantenuto,
quindi non era facile arrivare lì.
Ecco, questo ci ha permesso di arrivare
a quello che ieri sera anticipavo:
questo è un nostro percorso
verso la felicità,
una scorciatoia verso la felicità
perché qui noi abbiamo creato competenza,
capacità, economia territoriale.
E l'abbiamo fatto con la sostenibilità.
Qui vedete i nostri dati dopo dieci anni:
son dati piccoli, non sono dati
da miliardi di euro;
però noi, in dieci anni,
abbiamo fatto dieci anni
di gestione positiva.
È da sfatare -
io ho visto qualcuno che diceva no,
bisogna presentare i bilanci
con dei margini negativi,
perché se vedono
che è in perdita, si sovvenziona.
Fesseria gigantesca:
se tu sei già in perdita,
soldi non te ne daranno mai.
Allora noi -
(Applausi)
noi invece abbiamo sempre fatto
i margini positivi,
abbiamo raccolto in dieci anni
due milioni e mezzo di euro:
più 500.000 euro
che ci ha dato la Cariplo,
tre milioni di euro.
Se all'inizio di questa nostra avventura
avessimo detto tra di noi:
ragazzi, qui bisogna raccogliere
tre milioni di euro,
sei miliardi di vecchie lire,
non saremo mai partiti,
e non sarebbe mai partito nessuno.
Ecco perché abbiamo bisogno
dei piani strategici pluriennali,
fare le cose piano dopo piano,
passo dopo passo;
perché i risultati arrivano.
Noi siamo convintissimi
che abbiamo davanti progetti
ancora per lungo periodo.
E la sostenibilità
è una parola chiara, quindi:
se non abbiamo la sostenibilità,
questi beni decadono nuovamente.
Quindi dobbiamo immaginarci di trovare -
il nostro bilancio, per il 75 percento,
è dato da iniziative
che noi mettiamo in campo,
da contributi che andiamo a ricercare,
da sponsor che troviamo
prima di fare manifestazioni.
Il tempo è breve,
io devo stare nei miei tempi;
però - noi facciamo mostre,
ci propongono mostre da tutte le parti.
Non ne facciamo mai, mai,
neanche una di quelle che ci propongono,
perché costano una cifra pazzesca.
Le mostre ce lo costruiamo noi.
Le nostre mostre fanno
dai 6.000 ai 10.000 visitatori.
E cosa fanno le nostre mostre?
Propongono, assolutamente,
di andare a promuovere il territorio.
Adesso partiamo velocemente,
perché il tempo mi stringe,
per presentare quali sono
i nostri tre progetti
che abbiamo in corso adesso.
Economia circolare:
siamo assegnatari di un bando
sull'economia circolare di 136.000 euro.
L'economia lineare -
produco, consumo, faccio rifiuti -
ormai è al termine:
le risorse non sono infinite.
Dobbiamo pensare un nuovo progetto,
e quello che noi stiamo pensando
è che diventiamo, per l'ennesima volta,
esempio sul territorio
dove produciamo, consumiamo
ma riutilizziamo.
Ecco, su questo stiamo inventando
alcune iniziative, ci stiamo pensando.
L'altra operazione che abbiamo in corso -
qui, tra l'altro, vedete nella fotografia
questo bellissimo ponte di Giuliano Mauri,
che collega una roggia,
perché oltre a questo abbiamo anche
questi artisti di arte naturale.
Questo è sulla resilienza,
è un bando che esce -
quindi cominciate a incrociare le dita,
perché il bando esce martedì -
dalla fondazione Cariplo,
quindi mercoledì sappiamo i risultati.
Se va questo,
secondo noi cominciamo a pensare
che questo shock del territorio,
che è un'agricoltura massiva
fatta dall'utilizzo di granoturco,
che consuma una grande quantità
di acqua, anticrittogamici, diserbanti,
e ci rovina assolutamente il paesaggio.
Noi vogliamo invertire:
agricoltura di prossimità,
farro, grano, monococco -
creiamo la filiera del pane.
Chi mette il grano deve sapere
che chi acquista le farine
già glielo compra,
che poi il fornaio gli compra le farine,
che i gruppi di acquisto solidale
comprano il pane.
Piccola filiera, ma la facciamo partire.
L'albergo diffuso è un altro progetto
che noi abbiamo in corso:
perché il museo non è il paesino -
il museo non è il castello,
è il paesino a cielo aperto
che è il mondo contadino di una volta.
Ecco: lì noi vogliamo portare le persone,
che stiano lì a vedere la ricettività.
Perché nel frattempo, tra parentesi,
nel paesino di 76 abitanti
sono partiti tre ristoranti
che fanno 80 - 90.000 persone all'anno.
Quindi abbiamo creato questo indotto.
Già erano partiti all'inizio, anche loro -
ecco, quindi questi sono i tre progetti.
Poi, il futuro.
Perché il futuro non basta
solo immaginarlo,
il futuro bisogna anche scriverlo,
e quindi noi lo scriviamo
pensando di fare impresa sociale.
Il braccio della fondazione,
che è costituito esclusivamente,
tranne un dipendente, dal volontariato,
60 persone che lavorano con noi,
deve essere assolutamente rafforzato.
Bisogna modificare e integrare
la governance della fondazione,
creando l'impresa sociale.
E dando corpo alla nostra
nuova ossessione:
dare lavoro ai giovani.
Quindi, questi giovani devono entrare,
andare a ricoprire
i posti di responsabilità
dove andremo a creare
queste scuole di buona gestione.
La buona gestione
l'abbiamo dimostrata in dieci anni,
quindi credo che non abbiamo bisogno
di imparare niente, su quel lato.
Quindi, abbiamo dimostrato -
faremo la scuola di buona gestione,
la scuola di alta formazione,
la scuola dei camerieri.
Ci sono i ristoranti,
quindi attivare lavoro per i giovani.
Dall'altra parte, devono diventare
il braccio operativo della fondazione.
Il nostro volontariato,
che ha una certa età, come la mia,
quindi comincerà
ad essere affaticato dal tempo,
dovrà essere sostituito da questi giovani
che, facendo i responsabili
di queste iniziative
dalla cooperativa sociale,
diventeranno, anche,
la forza nuova della fondazione.
Quindi, questo abbiamo in campo.
E poi, per terminare -
ecco, credo di essere
nei tempi per terminare -
c'è questa idea
sull'artigianato dalle scuole,
tipo le botteghe del Rinascimento.
Siamo andati in Regione a dire:
questo è un progetto.
E questi dicono: sì, ma non è previsto.
È chiaro che non previsto:
sono venuto apposta
a chiederti di modificarlo!
Quindi questo -
(Applausi)
Guardate che se sforo è colpa vostra,
perché applaudite, quindi -
(Risate)
Stavamo dicendo: perché l'artigianato?
Perché il lavoro non si cerca:
il lavoro si crea.
Quindi, se noi creiamo lavoro
di piccoli, piccoli numeri,
li facciamo e andiamo avanti.
E termino dicendo
questo proverbio africano
che dice che tante persone,
in tanti piccoli posti,
che fanno tante piccole cose
sono in grado di cambiare il mondo.
Noi ci proviamo con il nostro metodo.
Ascoltando il nostro cuore,
perché esso conosce tutte le cose.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
GS: Lo prendiamo come consulente
perché noi, qui, nel nostro territorio
abbiamo molte cose
che potremmo rimettere in piedi:
però ci vuole il metodo.
DP: Se mi date un gruppo, noi ci proviamo!
(Applause)